this should have been a day of
diplomatic Triumph for Ukraine president
zielinski shouldered her shoulder with
the G7 leaders but it also turned out to
be the day on which the Ukrainian leader
acknowledged the total Destruction of
buckmut at a one-on-one meeting with
President Biden he was asked about the
city Mr President
I think no
but you have to to understand that there
is nothing they destroyed everything
there are no buildings later I asked
president zielinski for clarification is
the battle for the city still ongoing
now our people are accomplishing a very
important Mission they are now in
Bahamut I will not share where exactly
but it witnesses that Bahamut is not
occupied by Russian Federation as of
today like the other International
visitors here this weekend president
zielinski paid his solemn respects to
the victims of war the president 15
months after his country's Invasion by
Russia laying a reef at the memorial to
those who died in the world's first
nuclear bombing almost 78 years ago
Ukraine is only one of four countries to
have given up their nuclear weapons but
it still has nuclear power plants and
fighting around one of them zapparisha
has been heavy with so much still at
stake for Ukraine president zielinski
had meetings with some of the other
countries invited to the G7 including
the leaders of India Australia and
Indonesia but notably not with the
Brazilian president Lula de Silva he did
get good news on fighter jets the U.S
has dropped his objections on NATO
allies giving Ukraine f-16s my private
meeting with president zielinski after
the G7 meeting
and with his staff I told the United
States together with our allies and
partners is going to begin training
Ukrainian pilots and fourth generation
fighter aircraft including f-16s to
strengthen Ukraine's Air Force as part
of a long-term commitment to Ukraine's
ability to defend itself up to a decade
ago there was a G8 Russia was a member
until it was kicked out following the
annexation of Crimea in 2014. today
president zielinski was with the leaders
of the G7 as the representative of the
eighth country in the room it was a very
powerful symbol
but developments back home will have sad
the atmosphere for zelenski even though
many experts believe bakmut's strategic
importance has been overplayed it's a
place where so many lives have been lost
in the last year and the uncertainty
about its fate casts a shadow on
zelenski's visit here to another city
synonymous with the destruction of War
James Bay's Al Jazeera Hiroshima